[Music]
I'm going to go over today graph rag
particularly dealing with multiple data
sources. Uh so both unstructured and
structured data sources and kind of why
you would want to ever do that in the
first place even. So I prepared uh some
notebooks here. I was going to make
slides, but then I thought it would just
be easier to walk through some of what
this looks like in practice. Um, so
there's a link here, and I can share it
with you at the booth later, um, if you
have follow-up questions. But basically,
uh, what I wanted to show you first is
just what a general graph architecture
looks like, right? And so basically what
we do is we have our agents, right? We
have our tools just like you normally
would. But then in the middle here, you
see off to the side, we have this
knowledge graph. In this knowledge
graph, you can both extract data from
documents and unstructured places and
also have standard ETLs for structured
data. And so there's a big question of
why in the hell you would want this
knowledge graph thing sticking in the
middle there. And I could talk about
accuracy and explanability, but I think
what's really valuable to talk about is
kind of what this means going forward
with agents and how it's valuable for
agentic workflows. And as we think about
some of what agents can do with
reasoning and decomposing questions, a
lot of the retrieval that we're seeing
is not so much just a straight shot
vector search anymore. A lot of what
we're seeing is a question being broken
down and being handed multiple queries,
right, to go and pull the data that you
need. And the great thing about having a
knowledge graph is that you can express
a very simple data model to get started
to your agent which can help it do that
decomposition, pull information
accurately, and then as you sort of
expand, you can keep adding more and
more data. The example that I'm going to
show you here inside of these notebooks
is going to be for a uh employee graph.
So basically, think about a knowledge
assistant that's responsible for helping
pull information around skills analysis.
um look for similarities or
substitutions in a team and try to
figure out who's collaborating, where
skill gaps are, all that sort of stuff.
And the data that we're going to start
with today is just going to be in rums.
I just have these PDFs, just like a
folder of résumés, um that are pretty
standard. It just lists people's
professional experience and
descriptions. Um it's for a company
called uh what did we have here?
Cyberdine Systems, if anyone's familiar
with them.
a little Terminator reference. All
right. Um, so anyway, the first thing
that I'm going to do to just show you
what this looks like is I'm going to
load documents into the Neo Forj graph
database, but just sort of as like
basically documents ch basically take
every resume, put an embedding on it.
What it looks like here, if I was to if
I was to scroll here, is kind of like
this. So basically,
you know, I have these different nodes,
but you'll see the nodes are basically
just going to have some metadata, some
text, which is the resume, and then an
embedding. And basically what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to create an
agent inside of ADK, so Google's
framework. And I'm going to start asking
it some of those questions. And so
basically what you're going to see here
and I don't have time unfortunately to
walk through all of the code but
basically if you look at this agent
that's been constructed right I have my
agent I have some instructions to pull
data and then I give it one tool which
is a tool to go search documents right
and so I'm going to ask it a question
how many Python developers do I have you
can imagine right this is probably not
going to work out very well if all I
have is just documents because basically
it's going to tell me I five Python
developers and that's because I set K
equal to five right when I went to go
pull my document. So obviously that's
going to be wrong and I'm telling you
that that answer that answer is wrong.
So you could probably solve that with
doing some entity extraction and putting
more metadata right on your nodes. So
that's so that's fine. So then I'm going
to ask who is most similar to a
particular person in terms of just their
skill set or what they've done. Um and
again here what you'll see and I've told
it in the bottom to kind of explain what
it's doing. Um, if I go down to the
display here, um, it it'll tell me
basically here that what it's doing is
it's just going to be using search terms
to go pull information. So, this might
help you find similarity to a certain
extent like it knows, you know, Lucas's
as a full stack AI engineer and he does,
you know, Python, JavaScript, and some
machine learning stuff, I guess. Um, so
you can search for that and you can find
some similar people, but the logic is
still a little bit hard to control. It's
just sort of, you know, plain semantic
similarity search. Um, and as I start to
go down, I can ask questions like
summarize my technical talent and skills
distribution. It's not going to be able
to answer that, right? Because it needs
to be able to do an aggregation to
answer a question like that. So, if I
was to go up and look at the logic
again, or I'll go down here. Um, it
could say I search, you know, employees
resumes using certain search terms and
stuff, right? And it so it's basically
if I go down and ask these questions,
it's just going to be using search terms
to find things. And so that's not really
good enough for our use case because we
want to do analytics, we want to do
aggregations, and we want to try to find
relationships between people. Um, and
again, like in the last question, I
basically asked it to find who's
collaborating on lots of projects. And
all it can do is search for
collaborators, which is not really what
I want. Like what I want is to find
who's been collaborating with who on
different projects, right? And the
resume data, you know, might have that,
but it's all, you know, sunk inside of
the text and stuff. So, so it can't
really do that. So the question is now
well how do I think about basically
explaining my data to my agent and then
also making sure right that I have a
data model that makes sense. So if you
think about it, you can do this at the
data layer. You can think about how do I
want to model my data just to start for
some of these beginning questions. And
here it's basically like I want to know
what a person is. So I need that. I want
some concept of a person knowing skills
and then the only other thing that I
really care about is what do people do?
Like what things do they do? Right? Very
simple. That's just the data model that
I want to express. So I'm going to do
entity extraction of these documents to
basically create this graph. And really
it's going to be just slightly more
complicated than that because basically
what I need to do here is I actually
need to create a graph where right I
have instead of just doing things I have
publish built one led managed optimized
shipped things and then those things are
going to belong to different domains and
work types. um which is going to allow
me to kind of connect similar things
together inside of the graph. So it's
it's a little bit more complicated, but
it's it's the same exact concept. Um and
basically the entity extraction
workflows we use um are pretty um
self-explanatory. They use um if I was
to go here, I use paidantic classes to
do that. So I have concept of
enumerations on the types of
accomplishments and domains that I want
and work types as well. I define my
things. I define how someone does a
thing through an accomplishment. Um and
then basically I put that through um
another workflow. Um I think I use lang
chain in this case uh to basically
decompose those documents and spit out a
bunch of JSON and inside of that JSON
for example for this person I have their
skills right that I get in here and I
also have their accomplishments that I
get inside of here. Um, so I can go
ahead and load that as well into my
graph. And now I have a much more
expressive data model. So if I go back
to here and scroll up
and look at this guy, this is now kind
of what my data model looks like, right?
I have my people, but now you see how
they're connected by all of these
different skills that they have as well
as the things that they're actually
working on and how those things connect
to higher level concepts like whether
it's, you know, um building something
for a system or shipping code, doing all
those sorts of things. And now because I
have that expressive data model, I'm
able to start having a lot more
precision around the way that I get my
questions uh basically answered. So what
I do here after all this graph
construction which I already talked
through
is I create this other agent give it a
similar set of instructions. I tell it a
little bit about my data model in here
and then I'm actually going to be using
this MCP server that allows it to read
the schema and also generate cipher
statements. Um so this is an MCP tool
that we just have you know out on GitHub
that you can pull. Now when I ask how
many developers I have now I can
actually do a query that's going to
match on person nose scale Python and
because of that I get an answer that's
much closer to correct which is 28
developers right that's very simple
that's just aggregation but now I can
ask a similarity question right like I
did before who is most similar to Lucas
Martinez and watch this is the same
exact question and when I went to go uh
calculate that I got an answer that it's
Sarah and it will explain the reasoning
that it did. It searched for people with
who knew um the same skill sets.
Sometimes when I ask this, it will also
search for people who have similar
accomplishments as well. Um and it will
explain exactly like hey like I did an
overlap calculation in the graph to
figure out basically you know given the
number of skill sets they had and the
number of overlap this is the person
that I think is the closest. So the
benefit of doing this is that you have
much more control and you can go in and
filter exactly what skills people have.
So for example, if I knew someone
actually didn't have a certain skill or
did have a certain skill, I can audit
that. I can adjust the graph to be able
to make that work. Um and then similarly
as we go down to summarize a technical
talent distribution, um again I can
match on those skills and I can start to
answer these questions and actually get
numbers between how many people know
different skills. Um, and it can also
break down different accomplishments and
other things of that nature. So, you
just get much more refinement in the
types of answers uh that you get for
your questions. Um, I can also add
additional tools. Uh, so instead of just
generating uh cipher kind of um on the
fly with a language model, I can also,
and I'll show you what some of these
look like in uh my bigger screen here.
I can go ahead and
move this up.
So this is an example of finding people
with similar skills here that I'm about
to show you. And basically, right, I can
do these very flexible queries in a
graph database where I can say, hey, go
from person ID to this other person ID.
And as I do that, basically what I'm
saying in that top syntax there is go
out some, you know, zero to three hops,
basically. And so what that allows me to
do is I can traverse over both the
skills over the common systems over the
common domains they work at and all of
their accomplishments. Um, and if I
wanted to add something else to that
data model, maybe there's a
collaboration link or another project
link that would all get picked up inside
of that query. So there's a lot of
flexibility and also higher performance
um in a graph database when you start
wanting to do those types of complex
traversals.
Um, and that allows me then when I go to
find similar people again. So if I was
just to scroll down to my uh question
where I define my agent again, I give it
more tools. And then I can actually look
at who is most similar to Lucas Martinez
and why. And it will start doing these
queries. So what you see it get back is
like all of the results of what I was
just showing you earlier. And what that
will help with if I scroll down to the
response is now what will help me get
all of these specific numbers around the
skills and then also the domains now um
between the different AI and analytics
and data engineering and things that
they were working on. So there's more
explanability with the way that these
questions are being uh answered. The
last part that I wanted to show you and
I only have a few minutes left so I'm
going to go very quick is what happens
now when you want to add more data to
your graph. Right? So basically say that
we had this resume data but now we have
this internal data that comes from a
human resource intelligence system and
this tells me different projects that
people are working on together and
collaborating on. So I have basically
the same people that came from
resumeumés earlier but now I can see
different projects that they were
working on together. And the great thing
about graph is that it allows you to add
these things very flexibly. So if I go
back to my um to my notebook here, when
you expand a data model with something
like if you're if you're in sort of
RDBMS or tables, one of the assumptions
that I made when I was ingesting the
resumes initially was it was one person.
An accomplishment only had one person.
It was sort of this onetoone
relationship or really it was one to
many. But an accomplishment only had one
person because it was just listed on
their resume. But now that I um am doing
this thing with this internal system, I
can actually see people who are uh co-
collaborating and what that would mean
in a tabular environment is I would have
to create another join table, right? So
I'd have to do some sort of data model
refactor. But the great thing about
graph is that I don't have to do that at
all. I can just sort of create new
relationships. So this is very useful
when you're going from one to many to
many to many or when you're introducing
completely new node and relationship
types. It's very easy to do that which
is super important as we move very very
fast right with our agents and we want
to ingest new data quickly and kind of
build out our systems and pivot and all
that sort of stuff. Um and once I have
that information right I can start
asking questions about who's
collaborating with each other. Um so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create this is sort of what the tool
creation looks like. This is a lot of
the same tools that I had before. Um but
the tool that I can create here to find
collaborators will basically do this
match um it's all the way down here. It
will do this match to find people who
are working on the same thing um within
a certain set of domains. Uh so that's
kind of what the graph looks like that I
get returned. And when I now want since
I've added that tool basically what it
means is that when I ask a question like
which individuals have collaborated with
each other to in this says deliver the
most AI things right it can go ahead and
leverage that tool um and then it can
now return an answer that's much more um
you know exact and based on my data. So
now I know that Sarah and Amanda have
accompated on very specific um projects
and as well as I have other
collaborators here with supply chain and
such. Uh so that was my short
presentation. I hope it was helpful. Uh
if you have any more questions, I would
be happy to meet you at the booth and we
can talk more. Um but that's it for me
today. Thank you everyone.
[Music]